in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Evan
and Erica are Weathers hey guys how are
you doing well they've welcome welcome
thanks for being here where are you from
st. Louis Missouri cool that's a bit of
a haul at for five hours yes five okay
drive it or flight we drove very cool
here to do it debt-free scream how much
have you paid off sixty-two thousand
five hundred and seventy four dollars
and seventy four cents all right 62 or
fifty to sixty two sixty two okay very
cool and making what kind of money we
started out at thirty-five thousand
dollars in two thousand twelve and we're
up to 55 right now good for you what do
you guys do for a living I'm a
professional musician in the st. Louis
area mm-hmm cool and how long did it
take you to pay off sixty three thousand
bucks 31 months 31 months
excellent so two and a half years Wow
you guys have been living on it what did
you sell we sold a car with the car so
for um like sixteen thousand okay yeah
it was just a really bad purchase that's
we bought a house and then we bought a
car and then we actually downsized and
then a week later found out we were
pregnant with our daughter Charlotte
she'll be to next month and that was
kind of what got us rolling on the
intensity a child will do that kind of
make you realize like oh we have another
mouth to feed
no we have a kid we grown up yeah but
she loves rice and beans too so I love
it yeah very cool so 31 months ago
that's you found out you're pregnant
with her and that was your wake-up call
yeah that's what started this so tell me
is this story what happened how did that
how did you end up what you do yeah so
we just lived on a tight budget
like I said rice and beans and we still
love rice and bean so it's really good
and probably the hardest part for us we
were talking about this on the way here
was giving up eating out because that is
sort of like our fund money we love
eating out with our friends and food is
our love language so we my favorite
sport yeah so that was the story up
until about the beginning of last year
2015 we found out we were pregnant with
our second daughter and she was born in
October um but she was stillborn
and so we had done what you had
suggested was to stockpile cash in case
of emergency and so we had we'd been
doing that and obviously very unexpected
event in our lives and but it's because
of her because of millions were really
here to tell her story and how she was
able to impact so many people's lives
and also the story of God's faithfulness
in our lives because our church family
set up a fun page for us a fund page and
it was through that that we were able to
pay off her medical bills and the
funeral expenses and on top of that we
were able to pay off our cars and the
remainder of our debts that we had so at
the end of October when we made that
last payment it was a very very
bittersweet moment because you know had
worked so hard to get to where we were
and but it was almost like we were
running a marathon and we just got so
injured along the way that our friends
and family just kind of picked us up and
cleared us the rest of the way so we
would have chosen any other path to be
here but here we are and just people's
giving has inspired us and put us in a
position to give back and be in a
position to be able to do that for other
people Wow I'm so sorry that's a hard
hard thing to walk through yeah and but
there there's so much beauty in this in
this story with friends and family
carrying you across the finish line
that's a great metaphor as I was a well
painted picture I could see it as you're
doing that so that's very cool and what
was her name what did you name her name
is Milly Milly okay sweet yeah sweet
very sweet fun well so your church
stepped up your friend stepped up and
came around you and and good thing that
you had put a pause on the the debt
snowball and it piled up some cash
itself because that gave you a little
bit of margin you don't you don't need a
financial disaster while you're going
through a tragedy right
and so man on top of the the broken
heart at least the wallet was was where
you can give yourself room to grieve
right there was definitely a added piece
and then our house got broken into just
like a month ago and then just again
just such piece when it when you like
you say all the time is just like when
something happens and you're like well
it's okay like it's gonna be okay
because there's that financial piece
like it's not a trade you'd make as you
said and you never would make that trade
in a million years but when you've got
an umbrella and the storm comes it
changes everything
it really does Wow well that's powerful
that's powerful and as you said you
would have gotten here anyway right yeah
probably two more years just for car the
last car that we that we bought mm-hmm
yeah Wow so whose idea was it to start
this back when you first started it
definitely her okay alright so she's
pregnant with the first one it says all
right we're gonna be grown-ups now and
did you turn that she turned dave ramsey
into a cuss word in your house no no she
didn't okay he did not so how did she
introduce you to the idea that we're
gonna do all this it made the most sense
okay her for us oh okay so you got you
just listened to the show or you yeah I
got the Total Money Makeover book or
what read the book and I had actually
taken financial piece in college oh I
really wish that I would have started
way sooner we're actually teaching the
financial piece yeah starting on Tuesday
so cool well thank you for coordinating
yeah very cool well you got a story that
inspires and you know I got a friend of
mine that says having a testimonies a
good thing getting ones a pain in the
butt and there's so much beauty in the
the way God came around you in a time of
hurt that that this so yeah the you'll
use this for good in ways that that you
never imagined before this is over so
well done well done I'm proud of you
thanks
how does it feel to be dead
free oh good
just like that yeah that's it that's
exactly how it feels yeah I like that
that's that's a perfect description very
well done and is Miss Charlotte here
yes she's running around here all right
is she going to get in The Scream or not
yeah we'll gather up and she's how old
again
she'll be to unmark in March Oh perfect
okay all right oh she's beautiful
oh very cool pretty kid okay so I for
those of you not well you know I look
deeply into your radio you'll be able to
see what I'm seeing so hey this is a TV
program it's broadcast over the Internet
as well you can watch this being stream
you can watch it on your internet app if
you want and then the Dave Ramsey show
app and you'll be seeing all this right
now it's beautiful very cool you guys
are a beautiful family all right Evan
and Erica and Charlotte from st. Louis
Missouri $63,000 paid off in 31 months
making 35 to 55 a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
that's fun
Wow victory and the tears Wow
huh I can't breathe wow what a story
unbelievable thank you guys for joining
us very well done very well done open
phones here at Triple Eight eight two
five five two two five you're going to
live your life your life is going to
happen you might as well choose to be
intentional and control the variables
that you can control they couldn't
control everything that was going to
happen in their lives you and I can't
either
we can't predict we can't control we
don't know all these things but you
can't control the money around it and
make the money behave thank goodness
they did it put them in a situation to
walk through a very very sad time Wow
you can do this folks you just got to
decide - this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget one of
the best videos out there
you